Nikki knows what it's like when life
enters a downward spiral aged just 14
her mental health began to deteriorate
she sought help from Child and
Adolescent Mental Health Services all
camps I started to self-harm and tear
voices and attempt suicide so then when
I went to my GP they said it's not
serious enough to warrant a cam referral
and they didn't refer me for like
another six months or something so they
just waited for it waiting and waited
till it got to like crisis point Nikki
was ultimately diagnosed with
personality disorder post-traumatic
stress depression and anxiety she now
has the treatment she needs but says
others have not been so lucky I've had
friends that didn't get help at all
because they just wasn't taken seriously
or wasn't bad enough and they they
killed themselves I'll have a chat with
you
contact me this mother wrote an open
letter to the prime minister after
repeated failures by Cam's which she
says could have cost her ten-year-old
daughter her life
it wasn't until things got really bad
that she actually ended up crashing out
of school because school was struggling
with her as well despite their best
efforts that we were referred to an
inpatient unit because they just didn't
know what else to do I would describe
Cam's as being broken falling apart and
needs urgent help an urgent inquiry as
to how they can fix it
Sam has now conducted a survey of more
than a thousand parents who sought Cam's
referrals for their children the survey
found that 66 percent of parents said
they felt let down by cams treatment of
their child seventeen percent were
refused treatment altogether including
one parent whose fourteen-year-old had
taken an overdose and was hospitalized
33 percent said they'd resorted to
seeking private treatment as a result
and 32 percent said they'd been told by
Cam's professionals that their service
had been cut that's been criticised by
the former minister who negotiated the
extra funding at the moment we neglected
horribly about 75% of children and young
people with mental health problems get
no help at all
it's scandalous the government says it
will
it's commitment to invest 1.25 billion
pounds of extra funding in improving
young people's mental health services
the biggest transformation ever in the
sector
last year was having a bad time many
young people like the ones who wrote
this short film have praised the care
they received once they did get
treatment from cams but with continuing
concern that services have been so
underfunded for so long the greatest
worry is for those who don't offer
Hirsch Sky News